hi i'm kalyn i'm single and i would love
to date a guy that could cook so today
because i love chocolate three guys are
gonna make me some awesome chocolate
desserts and i'm gonna pick one to go on
a date with and here's the catch i won't
be able to see them and i can only pick
the date based on the dish i've been
single for a while so i would literally
love to have somebody to make me all my
meals and then tuck me into bed at night
let's see if i find that today
hi i'm adam and today i'm making a
triple layer peanut butter brownie so
first we're going to start with making
the brownie layer we're going to add
butter and chocolate chips to a large
mixing bowl we're going to microwave
that for a minute and a half so you're
going to want to let that sit for about
three minutes before you whisk it
together cooking is a great way for me
to show off my personality i'm fun i'm
all over the place and it's a great time
to try out new things after it's mixed i
like to use granulated sugar and brown
sugar what i look for in a relationship
is somebody i can grow with somebody i
can laugh with and somebody that
challenges me to be better so next i'm
going to add the eggs so i like to cook
for people i like to bring my energy to
the meal that i'm preparing so once the
eggs are mixed in i like to sift in
flour and cocoa powder so after i sift
in the flour i'm going to take the
spatula and start bringing in all the
ingredients together just make sure you
scrape down the sides as you go because
you don't want to lose any little bit of
it so i like to add chocolate chips to
my brownie it makes them super fudgy and
extra delicious so after we're done
mixing i'm going to pour this into a
square baking pan smooth it out and get
it ready to go in the oven for 30
minutes i hope caitlyn's a chocolate
chip brownie person because
it's something that i love once that's
done baking we'll let that cool down and
we're gonna move on to the peanut butter
layer this layer is super easy we're
gonna take a bowl of powdered sugar add
in some creamy peanut butter and use a
spatula to just mix it together i think
food is a way to a person's heart for me
the weight of my heart is my stomach i
absolutely love the fact that we get to
cook for somebody today and next comes
the melted butter and we all know i love
butter it goes on my potatoes it goes on
pretty much everything so i'm going to
take a hand mixer and mix this all
together this brownie is super indulgent
and super big so next i'm going to take
the peanut butter mixture we just made
and take an ice cream scoop i'm going to
go nine scoops on this and then we're
gonna spread it around for this i'm
gonna use an offset spatula to get this
nice and flat on top of the brownie
layer you're going to see i'm taking my
time with these layers i want to make
sure that everything is completely
covered and that we have solid layers
for each flavor so after you have that
peanut butter layer smooth we're going
to pour on the rice krispie treats make
sure you have the rice krispies evenly
spread across the entire thing and after
that we're going to put the entire thing
in the freezer for 30 minutes while
that's freezing we're going to make the
next layer the chocolate ganache this is
super simple we're going to take some
chocolate chips and we're going to pour
some hot heavy cream in there let it sit
for a few minutes and then we're gonna
mix it together and you should get this
beautiful shiny ganache as you see here
so at this point we're ready to pour on
the ganache now remember we're gonna
pour this on top of the rice krispies so
we wanna make sure we get total coverage
on this there's no reason we can't take
the time to get this completely perfect
i'm sure caitlin will appreciate it so
we're going to put this in the freezer
for 15 minutes to let the ganache set
and then we're ready to eat these are
super rich brownies so be aware you're
going to want to cut these a little bit
smaller unless you're a big chocolate
fan then cut as much as you want y'all
look at these layers i think the other
guys are going to be sweating i really
can't wait for kailyn to try these i
think she's going to be really impressed
with it hi my name is sri and today i'm
going to be making a triple chocolate
trifle first we're going to make
chocolate pudding to a medium sized pot
on low heat you're going to add whole
milk table cream sugar cocoa powder corn
starch salt you're going to whisk that
together and keep whisking for five
minutes until it gets thick i'm pretty
confident my cooking skills i pretty
much grew up in a kitchen my family
owned an indian restaurant for about 33
years i would give myself an 8 out of 10
with a little bit of room for
improvement because there's a lot i want
to learn once that's all complete you're
going to take it off of the heat whisk
in some butter and some vanilla extract
and then from there you want to make
this as super smooth as possible so what
you're going to do is you're going to
take the pudding and run it through a
mesh strainer get rid of all those
bubbles make sure it's really silky i
absolutely think food is the way to
someone's heart when you taste food you
smell food that also can reciprocate to
a form of love once it's all in the bowl
and all of the bubbles are gone it's
going to be very smooth what you're
going to want to do is take some plastic
wrap put it on top and then push it down
all the way to where it's touching so
you don't want to develop a skin on top
and then just pop it in the fridge for
two hours now we're going to be moving
on to the whipped cream for the whipped
cream what you're going to want to do is
combine heavy cream powdered sugar cocoa
powder into a mixing bowl we're going to
mix this together with a hand mixer
until we get stiff peaks usually it'll
take about three to four minutes
chocolate's like a good partner rain or
shine night or day good day bad day
they're always going to be there for you
finally this kind of brings us to the
most important part which is assembly
like every good relationship when you
build up to kind of getting to know each
other you build that foundation build
those building blocks once you get
married it kind of strengthens that bond
between your partner at the very bottom
we're going to add some chocolate pound
cake we're going to crush it up into
little pieces and make sure the bottom
is purely coated next we're going to do
the pudding and the whipped cream layers
i put them in piping bags so it's easier
for me to assemble i really wanted to
make this dish because over the
thanksgiving break a very good friend of
mine and his wife made this dish for me
and i really loved it and i knew kaelin
loved chocolate seeing how their
relationship has flourished i thought it
would work for me as well next we're
going to move on to the toppings and i
personally love oreos and twix so we
chopped some up and we're going to put
them right on top now you're just going
to repeat the process and then you're
going to drizzle on some chocolate
ganache make sure you cover the very top
of it and then on top of that you're
going to add some raspberries or
whatever you like of your choice and a
sprig of mint i think presentation's
absolutely important like the saying
goes you eat with your eyes first so
she's gonna absolutely fall in love took
me a long time to perfect this recipe
and i hope you enjoy it
hi i'm jesse and today i'm gonna be
making caramel brownie cookies i heard
caitlyn likes chocolate and i love
cookies so in a large bowl i'm gonna
whisk together brownie mix flour and
baking powder i'll also add vegetable
oil and eggs so next i'm gonna beat it
together with the hand mixer chocolate
is actually reminding my grandmother
because growing up as a kid she always
had a jar of hershey kisses on the table
and i just remember eating them and
eating them and eating them so i was
like grandma sauce so typically my
grandmother would whisk my hand but i'm
going to make it easier on myself and
use a power mixer make sure you scrape
the sides of the bowls with the spatula
so everything is combined so once the
dough is ready we'll bring on our baking
sheet and bring in our caramels so i'll
take a big scoop of dough put it in my
hand roll the roller roll it pat it down
like a little patty put my caramel in
the middle roll it back up and set it on
the pan so i'm going to repeat this a
couple more times and put them on the
tray make sure that you roll gently it
gets a little messy but that's okay so
we're going to take these and bake them
in the oven for 10 to 12 minutes i like
sharing food with other people it helps
me get to know them a little bit better
once they're done we bring them out and
we sprinkle the sea salt around them i
think kenny should pick me because this
dish is delicious and i think we'll have
a great time together so we'll transfer
these onto a wire rack and let them cool
so these are looking pretty tasty i
think kalin's really gonna like these i
really do hope that cannon does like
them let's find out the guys have been
working super hard on these dishes i'm
super excited to try them let's bring
them in oh my goodness
initial reactions this person's an
overachiever in like the best way oh
yeah they're all really pretty i feel
like if there's good presentation that
kind of means that they're just put
together i feel like they're all
probably pretty cute because it's all
like medium styled presentation if there
was bad presentation though that would
mean they were specifically attractive
because hot people don't have to try as
hard
they all look great i'm excited i'm
gonna start with this one i'm not sure
exactly what it is oh there's like
brownies in it it gives me like mud pie
like from when you were little but
elevated i just can't tell how much time
did they really put into this one
compared to the others wow
it's beautiful and i feel like it's
going to taste really good i'm not the
biggest fan of raspberries so that might
be an immediate tick but that's okay
oh my gosh wait it's chocolate the spoon
i totally thought it was like a plastic
spoon that adds a point back for the
raspberries
yeah i really like the texture the
chocolate spoon definitely shows that
they're like detailed i don't know if
this makes any sense but people that are
detail-oriented i always feel like
they're taller yeah definitely
tall we're all under six foot honey this
feels like something though that would
be easy enough for them to cook on like
a cute little night when we're watching
a movie i feel like this person has good
style to match the presentation now i'm
going to move on to the second one i
can't tell if that's like coconut on top
but not a big fan of coconut either
salt that's so fancy you know chocolate
they're very chewy okay wait i need a
bite out of the middle
that just made it a lot better so
there's caramel in the middle and that
just elevated it a lot because at first
i would have said it was a little bland
with the caramel it's like you spent
time on these i feel like they have
probably a really cool lights i don't
know why i should have christmas lights
across my room
i feel like this person might be older
she's in for a treat
not old now i'm gonna move on to the
final dish so this is like epic it's
very there's layers they really put time
into this is this like peanut butter
situation in the middle okay i can dig
it
oh that's really good it's almost like a
reese's pieces elevated it's very peanut
buttery but hold on i'm gonna take
another one going in for seconds oh
it gives me like kind of like i don't
know why nerdy vibes like funny
maybe like computer setup also lights
creepy do you have a computer set up a
nice video really yeah i really liked
all of these it's very hard to decide
but this one just kind of fell short i
think in the wow factor i think i'm
gonna have to eliminate
the cookies
peace out bro
hi nice to meet you
i'm justin kaylin feels very accurate
really the light's hanging across the
room thank you so much i'm glad you
enjoyed this good they were good
so now there is two
left they both had like that first bite
wow factor so it's very hard for me to
make my decision so i think the one i'm
gonna have to eliminate is
no it's me no the brownie oh
i thought you had it i thought i did too
good luck to you yeah congrats hi
nice to meet you i'm adam nice to meet
you i'm caitlin i gotta tell you the
computer monitors the nerds everything
was right oh my gosh sorry i'm psychic
they were really good it was very hard
to pick like you did a great job thank
you so much
good luck to you have fun i'm ready to
see who i picked let's get them in here
hi
how are you good nice to see you bring
it in glad you enjoyed it it was so good
genuinely i love the textures the layers
there was so much to it even though
they're raspberries i know don't lie i
saw that i'm glad you enjoyed it i'm
sorry about the raspberries but i will
do better next time you did say
something about movies and i'm a very
big movie buff so hopefully we can do
this again there we go perfect thank you
so much for making this dish for me i
loved it i obviously love love so if you
guys love love make sure to check out
buzzfeed studios rom-com book of love
coming to amazon prime on february 4th
through this whole thing i think you
learned a lot about me i think it's my
turn to learn about you so yeah i want
to take a trip let's do it let's do it
[Music]
you